I always wondered right uh not not to
get sidetracked we can go back into the
street this is entire thing yeah I I
don't know I've been like I always
wondered if because I I don't think any
of us understand the world of chemistry
yeah and I think when you're watching it
it's hard to gauge
I'm like am I watching someone who is
extremely knowledgeable and an expert at
what they're doing or am I watching a
guy who is just winging it and also just
seems really good like I don't like is
this a call ahead no I'm asking I'm
asking like like if I would have like I
on the level of like chemistry
professionals where where do you where
would you place like where would you sit
like
because like I I I don't know like
because I I it's completely out of my
depth and I'm like insane to us it's so
absurd to me when I'm like this dude
could tell me he is like one of the most
knowledgeable chemistry people of all
time and I'd be like yeah I believe
I should totally make that claim no no
no so what's kind of interesting is I
remember
I mean to Jump Ahead like I started
doing all the chem stuff after I
finished a biochem degree and I was a
lab tech then it ended up being uh a
chemistry Master student okay
and that's when I started I started
pushing the envelope of like things that
I felt were quote unquote like safe okay
I say like it's like I felt safe doing
them yeah but like I started just I
guess like being having more confidence
in myself but I would ask my lab mates
for help being like Oh what do you know
about this chemical yeah and it's when I
start to realize that like
most people don't know like a broad
range of chemistry right they're very
like specialized the moment you get to
grad school you start doing like
projects that are in a certain realm but
when you ask I'd ask the person well how
do you distill and purify sulfuric acid
and they're like I don't I buy it like
why would you do that and then I'd be
like well how do you work with bromine
and they're like I I've never worked
with it before and in chemistry there's
a lot of like I call them like Boogeyman
chemicals because people will never work
with it but they just hear from a friend
of a friend that it's really scary yeah
so when I was in one of the labs they're
like they kept saying bromine if you if
you like go near it it does this and
this if you get it on your skin you lose
like it was like so hyped up but
everyone stop your new bro meme drop but
everyone's just so fearful that like I'm
fearful wanting to make it right but
nobody can help you because no one's
ever made it right right and almost
nobody's work like a lot of people
haven't worked like I want to enrich
uranium no reason why just wondering
does anyone know how to do it but like
the reason I'm saying this is that I
start to realize that most people don't
have like a they know a lot about one
topic they don't have a huge range of
chemistry yeah so it's like so what I
realized that my skill was not being
great at one thing it was being like a
mediocre a lot of stuff so like you're
not gonna make any breakthroughs but you
you have a very good understanding of
the general I guess like any
breakthrough because there were some
things like for example like when I was
looking on making like I say like Aero
gel superconductors there's people
probably out there who know how to do it
properly but the info is not publicly
available oh so you made it so it's like
I have to come up with a method and it's
like for for example one thing I did was
ferrofluid there's no recipe on the
internet like no there was not a single
recipe or tutorial on how to make it so
like I was super proud when I came up
with something that was literally the
only method on the internet do you ever
get like a lot of people like emailing
you Italian foods like everyone but I
also I made it it's one of the most
finicky things ever like I've tried to
make it like eight times and it fails
like seven out of eight times and I
don't even know why but
it's like
your question was like am I really good
yeah I think I just built a confidence
of knowing like how to see something new
okay and then navigate it safely huh I
think it's also you have the confidence
to actually try it out physically right
whereas like as you were saying like a
lot of other chemists would just be like
be too scared to even try it yes and the
big promise since there'd be you can't
get there you have to find the people
who work with it specifically to get
help right because the average chemist
can't help you
um so even recently one thing I worked
with was hydrofluoric acid which is like
and the pro like a lot of these
chemicals that I would work with the
first time it's like legitimately you
don't see in the videos but it's like I
would be like shaky for certain things
because not only am I working with it I
have to film so it's sometimes like
weird awkward positions and I have to do
things quickly and but if I spill it on
me it's really bad right so it's like
not only am I working with the chemical
I like practice a little bit but you're
gonna get the shot but I'm not so
familiar that I'm super comfortable yeah
um and terrified and with hydrofluoric
I'd ask some people who work with it and
they'd give you tips but it's like what
kind of tips don't well you know you
know what you're supposed to do don't
get it on you yeah right right like
where you have to there's all the
protocols of like wearing gloves you
wear like a face shield you wear but
it's still like nerve-wracking because
you've never worked with it before yeah
yeah and you kind of just have to yeah I
think even if you're in a lab like we
trained some people when I was there uh
with chemicals that we would say they're
dangerous you can't get it on you and
like this people would be like shaky
right we would have to be like that's
just part of it like you have to get
used to working with it wasn't too crazy
but it's like when you come from working
in Labs where it's like all like more or
less just like completely stuff but the
other one is like
you just like don't you don't want to
breathe it in so you have to be careful
you're not going to die if you get it on
you like the stakes weren't that high
yeah it won't be a fun time but it you
obviously probably be fine but it's like
just because you've never worked with it
before you're like really afraid of
spilling it so it's like and you're
trying to like use like a glass pipe
head and it's like maybe put it in a
tube so you have to be pretty accurate
yeah and then when you see yourself
shaking that makes you more scared
because you're like now thinking you're
gonna spill it yeah so you have to I
find that that was a lot of
they're just building a confidence that
I'm like okay I've I've tried a lot of
stuff and do you ever worry that you
make it look too easy
so
it's actually a very good question
because that's what like not that fear
directly of like whether I think it
makes it too easy
but I feel like I make chemistry
look like
not it's not fun no no not like so I
won't say like fake yeah but it's kind
of like the movie version you cut it all
the [ __ ] up so yeah there's no it's all
clean it's not it's it's none of that
like I people don't know when I planned
my procedures like I plan
Beaker swaps and how it's going to
appear in the camera so it's like I
won't fumble with things so like I will
if I if I have to take a beaker out
right away I will pour with my left hand
and then move with my right oh I'll plan
like the movements of my hands and so
it's like I if I have to like switch
beakers and stuff I also plan how I'm
gonna pour it how I'm gonna add stuff so
it looks very clean like actual
chemistry is insanely messy yeah like
when I'm off camera doing tests there's
just dirty beakers everywhere like
things sometimes I spill things and they
fall over but because I plan it so much
like let's say there's something here
yeah I plan the direction that I'm gonna
reach in and I even practice how I'm
gonna reach
so I don't spill anything so I don't
knock stuff like if I'm pouring
something I think it's going to be
difficult I I practice like three times
before yeah because in your videos you
make it look very natural yeah it's very
very smooth yeah very very like that's
why I say it looks kind of like it's
like the movie version because I've
practiced and some of them if I do screw
up I will redo the same thing like seven
times until it looks smooth right wow
yeah I always wondered if you maybe gave
some people false confidence in handling
some of these chemicals yeah
yeah with how easy you make it look
bringing up liabilities
it's like watching a stunt man jump off
a thing and then roll you're like oh
it's so easy I couldn't do that and then
you do it and you [ __ ] it up it's like
it's like it's not it's not that it's
not your fault that you operate like
professionals handling it it's like I
always just wondered if there's ever
that element to it where you're like oh
[ __ ] I gotta I gotta make sure everyone
knows this is [ __ ] dangerous
yeah I try to like slip it in like I
know I've watched I've watched like the
bromine video uh the ones that you've
done with it and it looks [ __ ]
terrifying it looks like an Elden ring
[ __ ] smog appearing it's terrifying
you do get used to working with bromine
now like that's the one thing like after
a while
I'm saying I remember the first time I
made it like I was so terrified but then
now it's just like you because you you
know what it's capable of yeah like I I
don't think I tamed it I might have
spilled it on me before you know my uh
what like a splash on me and then you
why are you the thing is when you work
these are things you don't like and they
don't talk about like when you work with
it you have a bottle of salt like that's
not an antidote but it's like it's it
will neutralize it oh okay okay so it's
just like you when you work with it you
have to have that and so if it gets on
YouTube did you get it on you you just
like I would just ah and you spray and
it disappears instantly oh that's good
so it's like
[Applause]
gets on my glove you immediately take
the glove off like I still don't want
like
yeah you don't want to risk it obviously
you don't want to burn or anything oh of
course I actually have a scar here are
you serious what's that from from Acid
oh my God but that wasn't from filming
my own videos
it's actually fulfilling for will oh my
God I was filming or I don't remember I
think I think I was filming yeah I know
he was filming something was happening
and acid spilled on me but I didn't want
to ruin the shot
so I just like I let it go until the
shot was done he's just holding the
camera
why was just like
like I threw and through you know like I
I feel like there are a few jobs
anything for the shot yeah yeah I feel
that there are a few jobs that can
really and that video is never posted
Sam yeah I feel like there are a few
jobs that can cater not only to your
expertise but also your mentality when
it comes to danger and all of the ideas
that you want to do aside from being a
YouTuber I feel like getting the shot
like I've I've burned myself before and
everything just to make sure if the
shot's nice then you'll say that again
well I like I I mean I said I've gotten
burns like okay okay because like
um
just to make sure that I know how to
handle it
you know what the first video I ever saw
of yours was and this is before I ever
started like watching your stuff a lot I
remember just popped with my recommended
and I watched it and I was like what the
[ __ ] is this yeah it was one where you
bought like anal lube I knew you're
gonna say that because did that blow up
like back in the day because how old is
this video oh that was one of the first
earlier ones I remember I saw this
you're like I bought this brand new anal
lube never used and it was like as funny
as I don't I don't think that was a joke
but it sounded like you know uh no like
let me thinks he protests too much you
know it was I remember
like I obviously I remember doing it
yeah but I what were you making of the
anal lube again I was getting the uh the
local anesthetic out of it
yeah so what was funny though is like at
the time what year was this this month
that must have been 2015 or something
yeah this is like I remember I watched
this when I was like
I was still in like [ __ ] like school
yeah I didn't know that you you were you
were aware of uh those videos I watched
that one never watched you again for
like five years because it was like I
just watched this one video around it's
the interlude guy and then I remember I
watched I was recently watched back and
I'm like holy [ __ ] this is the same
voice as the anal lube dude so I
explained the anal Lucy so I in the
video I said like now I got this anal
lube like brand new sealed never been
opened I'm like crazy like that it's too
good so funny but what happened was it
was it was weird because like watching
that really in my head made me realize
how different my content is now because
my videos back then yeah I would just
drag and drop the videos into the editor
right I'd pick up a mic and I would just
us say stuff I don't even think I ever
really said the line twice I just
narrated what I saw yeah right sometimes
didn't even rewatch I I for the first
like I would say probably
three years of my channel I never
re-watched the video
I to this day do not even understand how
they're coherent because I would
literally just say stuff as I saw the
clips right right render upload and so
like but I remember with the antelope
part it was I think it was an actual
concern of mine that people
comments the comments would be like oh I
bet this is his so I think I was
actually defending myself right it just
makes it look worse but
watching this it was absurd to me I'm
like why did I say this not
sarcastically like I was genuinely
defending myself
that's good it's kid I'm sorry to bring
that up does everyone bring that up no
what's funny is that like that's one of
the ones that is brought up a lot and
even more even recently people shared
like a screenshot it was another guy on
YouTube
he was a complaining about YouTube
recommendations and he specifically
reference he's like what have I done to
deserve this recommendation he's like no
offense to the Creator but seriously
YouTube and I was like okay and even
like I took a photo of it I was walking
through I know maybe it was actually
sorry it was a different video okay
because I was walking through like Best
Buy yeah and I saw on the random
computer that one of my videos was
recommended this was like in 2019 and I
was like super proud yeah I remember now
it was not the end I thought it was
which one was it it was like making like
a
sedative or something right not as fun
not as fun no for a second in my head
for a second I thought it was the anal
lub one funny
recommended at Best Buy